Україна вже рік демонструє єдність з народом Білорусі та приймає усіх білорусів,
які після початку мирних протестів проти режиму Лукашенка у серпні 2020-го були вимушені виїхати з країни через загрози затримань, катувань та репресій.
Президент Володимир Зеленський обіцяє захищати вимушених переселенців з Білорусі.
Проте, як каже громадянин Білорусі Алесь Красовський, який вже майже рік у Києві,
у його песика на прізвисько Драка більше прав на перебування в Україні, ніж у нього самого.
Владні структури України до білорусів аж ніяк не люб’язні.
Зараз я нелегал в Україні. Тобто, грубо кажучи, ось, у мене болить нога, і я не можу навіть в лікарню піти.
Поліцейський пройде повз, перевірить документи, скаже: ага, ти - нелегал, а ну, і в лапи Лукашенка.
А там мене чекають. У мене там обшуки проходять.
Звісно, таких випадків ще не було, тому що в Україні до нас здебільшого добре ставляться і розуміють цю ситуацію.
Але водночас немає розуміння, що в нас не зовсім стандартна ситуація з імміграцією.
Треба щось вирішувати. Дайте нам можливість тут перебувати легально, тому що в нас дуже складна ситуація, дуже складна...
У нас у Білорусі палає дім.
Відверто вам кажу, я в цьому щодня перебуваю.
У нас там по 100 політичних в’язнів щодня, ну, принаймні по 50 щодня затримують.
Їх не одразу визнають політв'язнями. У мене брат зараз у в’язниці…
До минулорічних виборів у Білорусі Алесь Красовський був успішним програмістом, мав солідні заробітки, будинок, родину, друзів.
Це налагоджене життя зруйнувалося за лічені дні, коли почалися мирні протести.
Алесь був розробником кількох відомих опозиційних до Олександра Лукашенка сайтів.
Через реальну загрозу опинитися в СІЗО, він виїхав в Україну через Росію.
В Україні, які і всі інші іноземці, він міг перебувати без оформлення додаткових дозволів упродовж 90-та днів.
З початком суворого карантину під час пандемії коронавірусу всі органи влади перейшли в онлайн,
подати документи на оформлення офіційного дозволу на імміграцію стало проблематично.
У грудні 2020 року після акції протесту білорусів біля Офісу президента України уряд дозволив збільшити термін
дозволеного перебування в Україні для них з 90-та до 180 днів, врахував і ситуацію з карантином,
дозволивши подавати документи пізніше.
Алесю це, втім, не допомогло. Виїзд з Білорусі психологічно дався йому важко.
Чоловік увесь час працював, щоб оплачувати квартиру в Києві, і водночас, як і багато білорусів в Україні,
намагався допомагати тим, хто виїжджає чи залишається в Білорусі.
Зрештою усі терміни Алесь пропустив.
А оформлювати документи за гроші, за допомогою приватних фірм, принципово не захотів.
Каже, від України, яка обрала шлях євроінтеграції, очікував більшого.
Я б сказав, що немає претензій до міграційних служб.
Вони там якісь справи розглядають. Вони налаштовані загалом добре.
Питання в тому, що є купа якихось бюрократичних процедур, які чомусь не прибрали.
І через це є певні люди, які тобі готові за 5000-6000 гривень зробити документи на підставі якихось домовленостей.
Немає  якогось кришталево чистого шляху, є купа якихось варіантів, лівих схем.
За даними Держприкордонслужби, упродовж року в Україну  в’їхали  приблизно 161000 громадян  Білорусі,
виїхало з країни 158000.
Більшість з трьох тисяч білорусів, які залишилися, не мають необхідних документів на перебування в Україні,
кажуть в громадській  організації Free Belarus Center.
Відповідно до законодавства, в іноземців в Україні є три варіанти легалізації:
отримати посвідку на тимчасове/постійне перебування, отримати статус біженця або статус особи, яка потребує захисту.
За даними міграційної служби, за рік статус особи, яка потребує захисту, отримали дві людини, статус біженця не більш десяти осіб.
А посвідку на тимчасове чи постійне проживання  отримали приблизно тисяча двісті людей.
Юристи Free Belarus Center вважають, що міграційне законодавство України досі залишається занадто суворим до іноземців.
За роки після Євромайдану ці закони змінювали мінімально.
Тож у них все ще залишається багато чого з часів СРСР. Особливо у випадку розгляду надання статусу біженця.
Адже, якщо, приміром, немає родинних зв’язків в Україні, що дозволяє отримати ППП, то отримання статусу біженця - єдиний шлях для легалізації.
Процедура займає дуже тривалий час, багато місяців.
І люди, які подаються на статус біженця, перебувають у дуже складній ситуації, адже в них забирають паспорт.
Замість паспорта дають довідку, яка не є посвідченням особи.
Відповідно в юридичному плані вони стають чимось на кшталт "привидів".
Фізично вони існують, але вступати в угоди, ходити до нотаріуса,
відкривати банківські рахунки, вести нормальну господарчу діяльність - в цьому вони дуже обмежені.
Наразі є деякі покращення. Але Україна дуже не любить давати ці статуси біженців.
Через рік після революції в Білорусі уряд України в серпні ухвалює нову постанову щодо права перебування іноземців в Україні.
Тим, хто отримав дозвіл на імміграцію, а це перший етап на шляху до того ж ППП, термін його дії через карантин подовжили до двох років.
Проте білорусам, які не встигли податися на дозвіл на імміграцію упродовж карантину, життя ще більше ускладнили.
Люди просто фізично не встигали подавати документи.
Вони приїжджали з дуже стресових умов: когось побили, проти когось застосовували приниження, нелюдське поводження.
Відповідно, поки вони приходили до тями, усі терміни вони пропустили.
Але тоді діяла постанова уряду, що, мовляв, нічого страшного,
ніяких каральних заходів не буде. Тепер без широкого розголосу, тишком-нишком
цей пункт прибрали. Тепер білорусів можуть штрафувати. Приміром, якщо вони
виїжджатимуть з України, аби оновити термін перебування, їх мусять щонайменше
оштрафувати, а можуть ще поставити заборону на в’їзд на один-три-п’ять років, а то і назавжди.
Ситуація, коли, приміром, чоловік залишає в Україні дружину з дітьми
і їде на роботу в ЄС, а потім не має можливості повернутися, цілком можлива.
В Державній міграційній службі постійно заявляють, що виконують свої обов’язки
відповідно до законодавства. І серед успіхів називають те, що разом зі службою зайнятості
змогли тільки за три місяці цього року оформити документи на перебування в Україні
і право на роботу для майже 4 200 іноземців.  800 з них - громадяни Туреччини,
500 - Індії, 250 - Білорусі.  Це дуже мало, каже Юрій Шчучко,
заступник голови громадської організації "Білоруський дім України".
Багато  білорусів в Україні перебувають в доволі важкій фінансовій ситуації,
навіть якщо подали вчасно свої документи.
Адже програм підтримки біженців з Білорусі в Україні немає.
Я паспорт віддав в міграційній службі, і все,
не маю права залишити територію України, не маю права працювати.
По суті, людині нема за що жити.
Найбільша проблема для білорусів в Україні - те, що ми не можемо
офіційно працювати, навіть політичні біженці. Ми тут нікому не потрібні, окрім самих себе.
Тому ми об'єднуємося. А всі слова політиків, які кажуть: так, так, ми вам допоможемо...
Ні, ні, ще не допомогли.
Найбільше шансів для легалізації з офіційним працевлаштуванням в Україні
мають айтішники, яким президент Зеленський обіцяв податкові преференції.
Алесь - програміст, проте вважає це несправедливим, адже наразі в Україну
виїхало багато інших білоруських фахівців.
Він хоче звернутися до президента Зеленського, до Міністерства цифрової трансформації.
Як програміст він бачить варіант спрощення легалізації білорусів в Україні
за допомогою якогось електронного додатку  на кшталт "Дії".
Він навіть готовий разом з колегами це розробити.
Робімо те, що потрібно людям.
Тому що ми завтра побудуємо свою країну і поїдемо назад.
І ці люди будуть дуже вдячні Україні за те, що їм простягнули руку допомоги.
Або ж, якщо ця рука не буде протягнута вчасно,
у людей залишиться назавжди неприємний осад в душі…
Звісно, Алесь міг би в будь-який момент залишити Україну і виїхати,
наприклад, у Литву. Та наразі це для нього не варіант.
Його дівчина вагітна, Алесь хоче офіційно оформити стосунки.
Онак і тут виникають певні бюрократичні перепони:
в РАЦС від нього вимагають апостиль з Білорусі про розірваний раніше шлюб.
Юристи Free Belarus Center запевняють, що існує постанова Мінюсту, яка спрощує цю процедуру.
Тож одружитися Алесь таки зможе. Айтішник сподівається на подальші позитивні зміни
і розмірковує тим часом про проведення інформаційної кампанії,
щоб принаймні самі білоруси знали про свої права в Україні,
якщо чиновники їх ще не вивчили.